in our rapidly developing world the
demand for well-educated workers has
never been greater yet for many
education remains out of reach worldwide
250 million children are out of school
even more are unable to read write or
count every day of growing displaced
population abandons their education and
other struggle to find new modes of
education to balance work with learning
at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology we believe everyone should
have access to a quality education and a
better tomorrow to help make that a
reality MIT and community Jameel are
launching the Abdul Latif Jameel world
education laboratory or J well our
mission to bring together the best minds
to transform education and learning
worldwide from pre-kindergarten through
higher education to workforce training
mit has been a pioneer in the field of
digital learning opening our doors to
the world through open courseware MITx
edx and most recently the micro masters
credential
join us now as MIT and Jay well explore
education across cultures backgrounds
and ages and collaborate with educators
universities government nonprofits and
industries to find new solutions in
every area of education from research on
learning and curriculum development to
teacher education and public policy our
goal to confront the most pressing
problems facing education today and
deliver sustainable scalable impactful
solutions to the world as we transform
learning we transform lives together
let's learn how and do it
[Music]